hey there boys and girls it's your old
podcast pal Ralph here why don't you
check out the Ralph report that's my
Daily Show Monday through Friday you can
get an ear full of me and we have a
pretty good time plus if you're a
Hollywood Babylon fan and you subscribe
at the three or four star general levels
you can get the entire back catalog of
Hollywood Babylon the past decade of
babylon's for you to listen to at your
leisure plus the four star tier they get
to watch us record the show live once a
week plus there's a live stream events
all kinds of goodies why don't you go
check it out we're over there at patreon
go to patreon.com the Ralph report
that's
p-a-t-r-e-o-n-.com the Ralph report or
check us out at the ralphreport.com
it's time to babble the [__] on
[Music]
this Hollywood Babylon
with your hosts Kevin Smith and Ralph
Garman
[Music]
it is Saturday night in San Diego
everybody
at Comic-Con 2023 so let's Babble the
[__] on I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Carter
hey
you forgot what seats we set in didn't
you you're like I literally did I was
like am I on the right or left it's been
a [__] minute
um it is uh been an amazing Comic-Con
this is the end of Comic-Con for for me
after this I'm all done and stuff so the
last one ever ever No oh I'm sorry to
hear that um but I'm uh I'm [__] I've
had such a great time and I was looking
forward to tonight not because I was
like I want to be over but this isn't
the beautiful way to cap it we're at the
movies pop up here at the Tin Roof Inn
in San Diego for the second year in a
row with a sold out [__] house put
your hands together so Folks at home
know you're real
thank you for being here everybody we
appreciate it
[Applause]
to you my good friend yeah can we have a
conversation about what's going on here
yes I'm having a hurricane kids
for those folks can't believe they're
celebrating drinking at a bar
for those folks who aren't aware what a
hurricane is it's an alcoholic beverage
right Kevin Smith is drinking an
alcoholic beverage and I was I guess it
was a couple of weeks ago I started
receiving uh texts and emergency alerts
and uh it was an amber alert that came
on my phone but this is missing it's in
Smith's belly Kevin Smith is drinking
he's drinking alcohol famous the guy who
never drank booze is now drinking
alcohol yeah stay in your [__] Lane
that's all I guess I'm saying well
you've always made it look so fun and
because it is fun but it's not for you
it's my fun I I've uh I think of the two
I've seen you drunk yeah yeah when have
you seen me not drunk is the question
and it always made me scared to drink
because I'm like boy it turned you into
a bitter human being and [__]
how dare you sir but I I find the fruity
drinks like it put me in in a happy
place oh now you're seeing the magic
yeah I kind of I kind of get it man
careful it's a slippery slope my friends
in what way I'm just gonna book a double
room at a rehab for us just in case
that'd be amazing if we went to rehab
together and [__] that'd be a sitcom Mr
Garmin how long have you been drinking
here like [__] 50 years my whole life
yes Mr Smith how long you've been
drinking like two weeks
and I've got a problem I guess it
started with blue milks at the at the
scum and villainy cantina yes and now
you're just carrying it over to San
Diego and there's no stopping you and
here's the thing I know about you
because Kevin was the guy who went on
like all right I'm just gonna eat
potatoes for like a [__] year that's
what I'm gonna do that's how I'm gonna
lose weight all right I'm gonna smoke
weed but I'm gonna start when I wake up
and then I'm gonna put the last joint
down when it's dangling out of my mouth
when I go to sleep at night so I know
you're like a full commitment guy yeah
my fear is you're going to be you're
going to be a boozer of Epic Proportions
no not at all only during podcasts
every [__] day
but tonight I'm taking it easy last
night I drank 10 [__] hurricanes
Jesus
[Applause]
um but tonight just two for to start
with we'll see what happens
Hurricane Warning that's all
um I gotta give it up for to Dr Josh
Roush over here give it up for Dr Josh
does with Sight and Sounds of uh
Hollywood Babylon every week he lit up
like Christmas last night when I was
like can I get like a pina colada he's
like you're on a drink took off like the
[__] flash came back with [__] a
tray full of drinks and stuff 10 last
night it was amazing yes he kept feeding
me drinks all night long I was like I
think I'm gonna get [__] trying to get
laid did you have a hangover I did not I
woke up like uh everyone kept saying
last night like you better drink a lot
of water and I was like you better
[__] leave me alone
one of us but I woke up like totally
fine I although at one point like
that'll change well I guess if I made it
a regular thing but I was upstairs
earlier today we were taking pictures
and we were doing signings and stuff and
then after the signing was done I was
sitting there talking to Josh and at a
certain point I was like is it possible
that I might still be drunk he's like oh
yeah it lasts for a while
and I was like I was a little like
suddenly felt like hey man everything's
cool
it's weird because I like I haven't
spoke weed in like six months and [__] I
know and so I that was a completely
different
feeling like I could [__] drive and
did uh stoned many times not you know
responsibly though but uh yeah of course
in case there's any law enforcement in
the audience but I don't think I could
do that with a drink in me no you can't
no no I wouldn't recommend it no they
got organizations against that sort of
thing yeah and they have machines that
can measure how much you've been
drinking there's that as well so I
wouldn't recommend it but yeah this
ain't gonna be a regular thing cut to
the [__] TV movie
silent forever the Kevin Smith story
silent re-bob Kevin Smith has played by
Pat Oswald
just saying you know I have very few
things that are my own on this show let
me have the booze let me just have
that's my thing who's ain't a brand
everybody here is drinking they're all
[__] biting off your things so I
don't think I'm like in your lane as
much as
you know I'm seeing life through your
beer goggles and [__] yeah keep your
hands off my goggles done and done
it's a drinking buddy that's all
no I but I still think as much you know
10 hurricanes that's impressive but what
do you got right there yeah what are you
drinking there look he's got three
different [__] sip of that what is
that that's a professional
oh it was a generous just caring for
three people you're sharing sharing is
caring
yes
I'd like to think though when it comes
to our drinking that in the the
paraphrase Larry Miller the difference
between your drinking and my drinking as
he would say is the difference between
shooting a bullet and throwing one so I
I I think there's hopefully I'll still
I'll still be the king we should do a
night where we try to out drink each
other like [__] Marion Ravenwood and
Raiders of the Lost Ark shots yeah
yes yes shots of hurricanes
see that's the thing it's like I can't
like what are you drinking uh Jack
Daniels on the Rocks just [__] liquor
who's a nice yes wow so like this is
like drinking a high C or Hawaiian Punch
a real punch in the end of it a wine
back slap if you will but um yeah I
don't think that's that's too manly for
me this feels like like I remember when
I was in high school wine coolers
remember Bartles and games thank you for
your support yes that was like what I
drank I don't think I could ever go as
hard as that uh we'll see cut to six
months from now next week's show I'm
like [__] give me that Jack Daniels
no ice
just a bottle and a syringe
I'm going to take it anally
I hear it gets drunk faster that way you
know people do butt chug what what I
the way you said it made me feel like
you have butt jumped you're like you
know people butt chug it's a thing it's
an actual thing what is it you uh well
it depends on how you want to do it but
most people will uh douse a tampon in
alcohol usually vodka or maybe grain
alcohol
and then they'll insert it up their
[__]
then you could drive
no you're missing of course you won't be
the breathalyzer unless they breathalyze
your ass you're [__] good this is
ingenious who's got a tampon
no so you insert it into your rectum
yeah and then you insert it into your
rectum it's absorbed through uh
bloodstream your blood into your
bloodstream quicker than it would be if
you ingested it by swallowing it do you
know anybody that's literally ever done
that I literally do no one who's someone
who has done that yes
did you sit him down and be like you
have a [__] problem I couldn't sit
him down because his [__] was full of
alcohol
I had to stand them up and then have a
conversation with a lecture do you have
you ever you've ever butt chugged Josh
[__] no
well we have a goal for next year's
Comic-Con actually man that's how we'll
sell out even faster very special butt
chugging episode of Hollywood it feels
more like a home show we just think so
we should do that on the Ralph report
just [__] talk about it just naked
from the waist down butt chugging doing
a doing a podcast
yikes before we get any further in the
show tonight I want to thank our friends
at manscaped.com our sponsors for
responses everybody
[Applause]
don't forget it is summer that means
barbecue season so take care of your
meat that's what they want you to know
nice
they got good copy man they're good uh
the performance package 4.0 has
everything you need to take care of
everything below your belt it's got the
lawn mower 4.0 trimmer which has got an
LED light on it which I particularly
like that's why I like their trimmers
you can see all the nooks and crannies
while you're shaving it's like a laser
targeter and [__] like exactly a red
light on your balls it comes with a crop
preserver ball deodorant because you
don't want smelly balls in the
summertime that's a real issue
um you manscape you take care I do I'm a
I'm a big trimmer yeah what's the idea
there make it look bigger how dare you
no it just keeps it neat and clean for
my lady and also keeps it uh you know
with summertime especially you want to
keep everything nice and dry and
deodorized do you um like I I work on my
beard and I go in they escape I do all
the time and I constantly go in and kill
any white hairs I see I trim those out
oh yeah because my beard is like slowly
gentrifying the whites are trying to
move in and I'm trying to
so I'll spend a lot of time like [__]
Mr Miyagi just trimming up my [__]
face like a bonsai tree do you get gray
hairs on your [__] dick at all
um not that I've noticed
you look uh yeah but I can only see so
far I mean I'm
I'm not Plastic Man for [__] sake I
can't get my face down there but that's
not a part of it you don't I tighten
everything up so anything that would be
white sort of Blends in with the
pastiness of my skin so I don't really
notice so much fair enough man uh they
also have available the manscape boxers
the shed travel bag shears 2.0 which is
great for taking care of your feet it's
summertime you're wearing flip-flops
around by the pool you don't want their
nasty toenails to be turning people off
and stuff I personally don't wear
flip-flops uh period but I I just found
out this weekend that Jason Muse does he
gave up on shoes all together
alternating he was just wearing [__]
flip-flops and [__] but he he hates [__]
between his toes he's one of those
people so we have these flip-flops that
aren't technically flip-flops but we
only found this out because we took
pictures as Jay and Sal and Bob the
other day right and he didn't have
[__] shoes and he's like can I do it
in flip-flops I was like that's against
Canon like [__] you've never done
that in a movie you have to write a
whole new movie now totally Jay and
Silent Bob lose their shoes but he would
benefit from that [__] shears thing
man because I saw his Grody ass nails
I'm gonna let him know how does he get
that you should go to manscape.com
we've been doing this a while okay I
think I like you drinking yes it puts me
on point I'm telling you I'm ready to
drive
bring my car around please
uh you get 20 off and free shipping with
the code Babble at manscape.com once
again 20 off free shipping at
manscaped.com and use our code Babble
patronize the good Folks at manscape
they're looking out for us look out for
them give it up for the manscape
manscape.com
[Applause]
well I was manscaping before it was cool
because I was dating an adult
Entertainer years ago
and what she demanded that sort of thing
yes why because it was the it was the it
was the person you make demands in
return like stop being an adult
Entertainer no I didn't I wouldn't I
wouldn't miss that of her it was her
life but she was used
if I wanna if I wanna you know if I
wanted to show up and look like the
people she was working with I guess I
had to take care of business so you were
involved with her one she was still
involved with the business yes she was
she was a big star it was a Ginger Lynn
I'm talking about before I met her she
was a big star and then uh she took a
break and then she got back into it
again and she was like you know you look
better if you just cleaned up a little
bit and so she did the first version she
did the first pass right and I was like
all right I'm just going to replicate
this forever
I I think the thing that is least
interesting about dating a porn star is
your grooming what the [__] was that
like man like [__] like was were you
constantly like was it like Chasing Amy
where you're constantly comparing
yourself and worried about like no I I I
don't have that Gene I'm not a big
jealousy person is that right yeah so it
never really crossed my mind I was like
that's not your [__] mind that it
crosses she went to work and then she
when she come home we talk about our day
and her day was a little different than
mine that's all
third day at work involved a few more
[__] than mine did I guess that's what
I'm saying yes I mean so at the end of
the day was she like well I'm a little
cocked out no and she surprisingly
they're very capable of uh
differentiating between their personal
lives and their professional lives
believe it or not it's a job I know it
sounds crazy but for a lot of people in
that business it's a job I'm sure not
everyone but for for her in particular I
guess too like you were on the radio
it's not like you came home and stopped
talking or something like that yeah I
talk here yeah she's like I [__] there
I [__] here and I [__] here
so that's how I was introduced to
manscaping and I'm now I'm a sure the
good Folks at manscape are like yeah
that's a great ad for it is
manscape.com should say yeah gingerlin
approved they can actually use that
because she would approve of that good
to know man all right you're a man of
many shades I am and most of them are
all white
let's jump into the program you know
kids we like to talk to folks who come
here from particularly long distances or
celebrating special occasions with us
one down number two
[Applause]
of course everyone's celebrating a
special occasion tonight because we're
all here at Comic Con [__] hey man
give it up for Comic-Con 2023. it's time
for the shout outs
[Applause]
[Music]
get your [__] out
just like Ralph's EX
not even close enough I only did the tip
you didn't get to the cord that's true
see that's another thing about booze it
gives you a false sense of inflated
security about your behavior that's true
I was like that was enough exactly yes
uh John Fink John Fink the vegan giant
are you here John what's up
if you listen to the Ralph report at all
you're familiar with John Fink he's a
frequent contributor and friend of the
show John's here tonight and he wanted
to say I want to thank you and Kevin for
your years of inspiration and
encouragement Kevin always talked about
art begets art do your own thing and I
did
John changed careers and now he's an
anchor and reporter for I Heart Radio
he's doing news for them [__] hey man
[Applause]
well done yes
I also be remiss if I didn't thank my
beautiful and extremely patient wife
Karen who is here with me tonight but of
course as poison taught us he says Every
Rose Has Its Thorn
so I'd like to get some advice from the
Germans about how to keep a jolly and
happy tone all day while I'm sifting
through the newswire reading about
non-stop death and destruction those
Germans are just so upbeat he said
thank you John Fink John I think the
Germans could give some advice sure Josh
girlfriend
anyway you know how you stay happy you
drink
that's what you must do John you must
when you're doing your work you must go
to a beer garden and have multiple
Steins of a beer while you're drinking
yeah yeah and also date a porn star yes
that would make you happy too yeah shiza
Essen the Germans now in the face of
horrible uh facts how to stay happy I
think imagine
like Hitler when the war was over did
he bad did he despair no he killed
himself that's true yes
or did he fake news did he did he go to
Brazil let's make some boys ask the news
boy he went to Brazil and made boys I
saw the movie with Gregory Peck and it's
like we may not see babies and as I know
that it was
not the fake news that is the oldest
reference made at Comic-Con this year
trust me there's more where that came
from
wow man I was like you pull the boys
from Brazil reference yeah [__] hey
you're old Ben
so are the Nazis that's a good boy in my
defense World War II was a while ago it
was a minute ago that was an excellent
flick though it was a good movie well
worth watching yeah we also get emails
from speaking of hold on I'm sorry what
happened speed is what happens when you
drink you interact because I got one
more [__] thing we were talking about
movies yes have you seen I haven't
caught up with you did you see it's been
a while have you seen the flash I have
seen the flash what did you think of
Adam West popping up in the flash loved
it right yes I was a lot of people
online were like this was so
disrespectful but I didn't think it was
how was it disrespectable respectful to
uh
yeah I'm handling my hurricanes Hammond
how is it respectable now how is it
disrespectful to honor someone's
contribution to the world of uh pop
culture and superheroes agreed
it was shitty quality yes but I'd rather
have shitty quality than not have him be
acknowledged at all so I was like
I like seeing all my old friends from
all the years of of following this kind
of uh superhero stuff yeah and so I I
was fine with it I was the least of my
problems with that movie quite frankly
was Adam West and George Reeves you
didn't like it I saw it four [__]
times
no I wasn't I love Michael Keaton Batman
is my [__] yeah my
trust me that got me through that film
yeah I could I I I don't need Ezra
Miller talking to himself for two hours
I don't know I didn't need that much
yeah it's like if you don't like Ezra
Miller here's twice of it yeah man but
oh my God Michael Keaton is Batman like
that was a joy for me made me feel like
a kid again not since 1992. did we get
to see him in the suit and [__] and it
was almost like getting an unofficial
third Batman movie I agree you just
happen to have the Flash in it it was
more like Batman with the flash yeah and
and I loved uh him old and with a beard
kicking pots at people's heads and all
that stuff that stuff was okay but the
moment he put the [__] suit back on
and [__] he just got right back into
that place like I loved one of my
favorite moments in a movie theater this
year I know a lot of people did not like
the flash but was him going how much do
you weigh
which like hearkens right back to the
other movie and I was like that is so
[__] wonderful that years later the
motherfucker's still doing mental math
in his head to be Batman like I love
that there were several of those moments
where they sort of uh revived old
phrases from that film well I'm
definitely saying I'm Batman was
[__] you want to get nuts that was
another one but that was cool too yeah
yeah but for the for the it was I was
fine it was fine um have you seen
Indiana Jones I did and I loved Indiana
Jones did you really yeah I know it's
not a popular take and a lot of people
had problems with it but I really
enjoyed it I think because I'm the same
age as Harrison Ford and so that's why I
felt I could relate to it to a certain
extent because I like those move how
where do you like it can compare to the
other ones me and Josh were talking
about I think I like all the Indiana
Jones movies in order of the way they
came out when I was a kid I elevated
um Temple of Doom because it was like
this is [__] metal but the older I
got I was like no Raiders is actually
the best Oh by far by far so I've liked
him in that order I liked Raiders I
liked Temple of Doom I liked Last
Crusade I like Crystal Skull and then
down here I like the last one really
that far down yeah it wasn't it wasn't
as tight for me as the other
[__] you I couldn't have an opinion
you're gonna make me drink
style of Destiny made me like Temple of
doommore which I wasn't really a fan of
why because it is a it's a it's a
bookend piece to that film in a lot of
ways explain
Temple of Doom is a prequel to Raiders
yeah in the beginning of that film
Indiana Jones is pretty much a mercenary
who is selling artifacts for money yeah
he has lost he has not yet gained the
sense of what it means to care about and
preserve the past which is weird because
in the beginning of the Last Crusade
he's like this belongs in a museum yeah
he's got Integrity there as a kid he did
and then he lost his way somehow and
then at some point as an adult he became
a mercenary and then he had to
ReDiscover his love for Antiquities
again which he does in Temple of Doom
because he's rescuing these kids he
finds a higher calling for what's going
on did you get did you they didn't
that's not in the movie you just put
that together yourself right no what in
Temple of Doom well I know he rescues
the kids but this whole [__] like and
that's where he found his heart again no
he did because he decided are you
confusing this [__] with the Grinch
Saves Christmas no no no he decides to
go back and rescue those kids rather
than just haul ass and take care of
himself and get out of that situation
and you think that was meant
intentionally to be like and that's why
he's the man man he is and Raiders oh
absolutely yeah oh he grows enormously
in the course of that film you're gonna
make me want to watch that movie again
you should because there's a real Arc
for that character that takes place in
that film that a lot of people
um ignore I think in my opinion A lot of
people that that is as reflected in dial
of Destiny a lot in the Phoebe worthy
amen you should care about this [__] and
she's not that way but she also like he
does in that film sort of discovers her
appreciation for that and it's also the
story of a man who's at the end of his
life and he's he's he's living out of
his own time and it's it I just found it
I thought it was a beautiful summing up
of the history and the Arc of that
character I wish they would have stated
it the way you just stated it I wonder
if they would have had him do it what
would have sounded like
um
when I couldn't change the language and
I'm going and I was like no
[Applause]
so basically that's what it would have
been like
we um but when he's talking about what
he would do if he could go back in time
yeah I was I was bawling like a [__] in
the theater I um I saw my friend uh
Ernie O'Donnell Smith mod Kessel keeper
Ernie O'Donnell right at my movie
theater back home and stuff my childhood
friend after the movie he was like
wouldn't it been better if he went back
in time and met Abner Ravenwood and I
was like my God that would have been a
[__] yes I would have so enjoyed that
[__] movie but instead he went to
Rome
all right I'll [__] leave it right
there no no no tell that I'm really
offending you no the Toby Jones
character uh yeah I understand a lot of
people like I've never heard of that
character before and I was like well
maybe Indiana Jones has a life that you
just aren't privy to maybe he's got
other friends you don't need to know
everything about him I remember I was
like down on uh Crystal Skull and then
Josh was like you should re-watch it
it's a good [__] movie's [__]
great yeah and we rewatched it at
smodcast one night and it's [__] it
is good and then I also realized while I
was watching I was like I fell asleep
for 45 minutes when I first saw this the
first time because I woke up and there
was a spaceship I was like what the [__]
happened I'm out of here and [__] but
then when I was awake for the whole
movie I was like this is actually pretty
[__] good I hope you slept through
the point where Shia LaBeouf was
swinging through the trees like Tarzan I
hope that was one of the parts where you
slept it's two-thirds genius and
one-third pure trash but I'll take the
two-thirds genius yeah
um but no I I enjoyed it did you see
that I have not seen that yet no I'm
waiting to get clear
yeah nice no one got that but people at
home would be like oh Scientology I
understand those three movies
it's a way homework we're gonna give a
handout to everybody
references to the jokes as a movie
theater owner like now I watch movies
just not as a fan and also as a
filmmaker but now I'm an exhibitor yes
you are so it [__] matters like if a
movie it doesn't matter how I feel about
a movie it matters more now how an
audience feels about the movie because
that's how we [__] earn not by
selling tickets to the movie because the
studios take like 75 80 of the ticket
it's by selling [__] popcorn I'm in
the concessions business and [__] so
when you have a movie that everyone
wants to see [__] you're selling a
lot of popcorn and [__] Flash like pun
intended was in and out of the [__]
theater we sold very little popcorn for
that movie
Ernie sent me a picture last night of a
[__] line down the block normally
when we do events it's my guys like
we've done uh the Hollywood Babylon
there we've done screenings like Chasing
Amy with Jason Lee with Jersey girl with
Raquel Castro me and Jay have shown Jay
and Silent Bob Strike Back packed
audience lying down the [__] block
and it makes it look cool and stuff like
that reminds me of my childhood
Ernie sent me a picture last night of a
line down the block and I didn't have an
event going on there and I was like what
the [__] he's like dude barberheimer
oh both of them are open this week
Oppenheimer playing at the theater and
[__] people came out in droves man
that Barbie movie looks like he's gonna
make 130 million this weekend if not
[__] more crazy isn't that [__]
nuts and so it's one thing to be like
holy [__] Barbie's doing record business
there's a three-hour movie about the
nuclear bomb and that's gonna make over
50 million [__] bucks so like right
now like I always appreciated uh Chris
Nolan because I love the Dark Knight I
love what he did with Batman and stuff
like that now I just want to suck his
dick I sold so much popcorn
because of Chris Nolan fiber seals
absolutely man if I ever see him it
ain't gonna be like you're a brilliant
filmmaker I'm gonna be like thank you
for putting asses in our [__] seats
and [__] and if I see Greta gerwick I'm
gonna suck her dick as well because
[__] that Barbie movie's got a ton of
people going to it nothing makes you
hungrier than nuclear Annihilation I
guess action figures and three hours
although Josh was saying he heard did
you hear this that like you know Chris
Nolan's like go see it in IMAX that's
the way to see it he says that about all
his films of course he does but tell him
what's happening with the IMAX ah shit's
just breaking down constantly because
it's like what 10 miles of [__] film
oh really systems are not designed for
that [__] oh that's funny it's too
long for IMAX most films are digital now
but of course the IMAX format is film
large frames of film and they still have
to put it through a projector right but
generally speaking they've never really
done three hours movies so apparently
like it's breaking down where people are
going to see it people like I don't know
what happens no no history happens
[__] they drop the bomb
just like making up for it totally for
missing explosions uh which I guess like
you know if it broke down and you were
watching it it's like the Titanic
breaking down you're like I don't know
what happens in the third act it's like
yes you do yeah
it's not good
this [__] don't work out for Humanity
but two huge movies those are the movies
look like they're saving the summer box
office I'm looking forward to both of
those films obviously for very different
reasons but I think Kelly and Murphy's a
brilliant actor I'm a big fan of do you
watch peaky blinders at all I saw the
first season and then I fell off not
because it was bad just because other
[__] happened in life yeah but uh and uh
it is wonderful and so is Margot Robbie
I mean just here's the thing two films
that are monster Hits one film as you
mentioned everybody knows the end of the
story yeah and the other one's an IP a
character that's been around for 50
years plus and it shows if you do
something in a clever inventive original
refreshing way people will show up and
they'll go to the theater there were a
lot of Articles this summer about like
IP is dead intellectual property uh
seeing the same old [__] people don't
want to do that anymore flash crashes
Indiana Jones crashes Mission Impossible
open soft and stuff but now Barbie is
the old
[Music]
but I've been around longer than a lot
of that [__] and still people came out
for it so I think it's that I think hey
make a great movie people show up and I
haven't seen it yet but it sounds
[__] wonderful I've talked to people
all weekend long who went to Barbie and
come in like profusely [__] praising
it but Warner Brothers did like a
[__] killer campaign for that movie
for Barbie because the trailer was like
if you love Barbie you'll love this
movie if you hate Barbie you'll love
this movie yes
that's when they had my money I was like
I hate Barbie
how can you hate Barbie our kid wasn't
allowed to play with Barbies wasn't
allowed oh Jennifer's like she gotta
play with [__] Barbie like that
Barbie had a bunch of careers and [__]
she was like a woman my wife didn't want
our kid to know about those careers
[__] housewife and that's that that's
smart yeah that's a good idea yeah I
know Jen that's what she was concerned
about yes
uh but you know what the thing is older
IPS it's going to be trendy next thing
up Checkers the movie I'm telling you
you're gonna get it it's gonna happen
What will Barbie Inspire like what well
if somebody looks at Barbie and goes
holy [__] they opened huge movies gonna
make a billion dollars what is the next
thing to grab like yo-yo in 3D Slinky
Slinky yeah
or not okay
but there's no like you know how like
when you do a thing it's successful and
then somebody like knocks it off like
Star Wars was successful and then
Battlestar Galactica happen and [__]
right is there a Girl doll
the American Girl doll
American Girl dolls
they all die of plague
if you love plank this is the movie for
you if you hate plague this is the movie
for you American girls
um what toys have been successful they
can make oh [__] you know what toys
always sold well and they can make a
movie of Star Wars figures good idea and
as you do a Star Wars movie yes
Mr Potato Head we got one of those I'm
gonna did I [__] show you I'm a Mr
Potato Head what now they did a Silent
Bob Mr Potato no way dropped for Comic
this Comic Con has been like [__]
wonderful for me in terms of the stuff
we sell because they did a pop Tater
it's called so it's a Silent Bob Mr
Potato Head and Jay saw it was like
where's the Jay I was like they didn't
do it and he's like what the [__]
I was like that's right [__] I'm a solo
act now man [__] Paul Simon you're
our Garfunkel and [__]
but they also [__] did uh tops did
Garbage Pail Kids ask Universe cards
which we're selling here they're they've
been going like [__] hot cakes and
it's all the characters from these
Universe movies but done as Garbage Pail
Kids that's awesome that brought a tear
to Jay's eye he was just like this is
the greatest thing that's ever happened
to us as characters I was like we're in
the [__] cement at groman's Chinese
Theaters not Garbage Pail Kids but he's
like I collected this I never even went
to that movie theater
but he was so [__] happy he's wearing
the T-shirt all weekend [__] with
thinkers they're doing t-shirts as well
and he's been wearing it he hasn't taken
it off for the three [__] days he
keeps sending me pictures he's still
wearing the same [__] T-shirt with
him as a garbage pill and the [__]
flip-flops yes yeah
so [__]
[Laughter]
we also get emails from all around the
world Josh
got an email back
featuring Kevin's reactions that's right
uh this comes from JT in Pottsville
Pennsylvania
Ralph and Cavs so glad to have the show
back it makes my drive to work less
sucky one of my favorite movies from
last year was Elvis yeah that was that
was a good movie Austin Butler Austin
Butler my co-star from yoga hosts yoga I
taught him taught him everything he
knows that's right he learned it from
you that's right he oddly he didn't
mention yoga hosers once on the Press
tour I noticed that he didn't bring it
up I thought he'd be out there going
like [__] I was in this movie once
but no no
would we be able to hear the classic
Elvis hit Suspicious Minds as sung by
TV's Batman Adam West for Comic-Con
JT from Pottsville Pennsylvania yeah I
was on the floor rocking my Adam West uh
shirt uh today it was fun people were
coming up like who's that it's like shut
up get out of here that's Batman no it's
not man for God's sakes all right Adam
West singing Suspicious Mind sure we can
do that Josh
we're caught in a trap old chunk
I can't walk out
because I love you too much baby
why can't you see
what you're doing to me
when you don't believe a word I
say
we can't go on together
with suspicious minds
and we can't build our dreams
Suspicious Minds
[Applause]
[Music]
Ryan in Washington state writes my
girlfriend has introduced the idea of a
threesome into our relationship however
the third she has in mind is our good
male friend I'm more open-minded than
most and want to make my girlfriend
happy but I'm on the fence about this
can sexy Kevin lay out the pros and cons
of such an arrangement so my girlfriend
and I can make an informed decision
I like maybe yeah sure
I guess I don't know you tell Ryan in
Washington state the pluses and minuses
of a MMF as they say in the business
sexy cabin music oh Ryan the plus of sex
is that you come
the minus of a threesome is there is
more come than you need
think twice
fair enough wow it's a saint that's a
PSA right there
[Applause]
and lastly uh Dan Ruiz writes in uh
Ralph Kevin and Josh Josh you're
included on this email by the way nobody
cares about me yeah he does Dan does Dan
writes in this is this is Dan's thing oh
my God that was [__] adorable we do
um
we've been doing this thing lately where
I sing they're coming to take me away
huh yeah the novelty song would it be
possible here Jack Nicholson sing the
novelty song they're coming to take me
away haha right Stan Ruiz did you do it
Nicholson I haven't done in a while hold
on a second I gotta pull this out
there's a law that says if you do it if
you do a Nicholson impression you have
to you brought props holy [__]
well I feel more like Jack already
all right they're coming to take me away
Josh
remember when you when you ran away
that on my knees and begged you not to
leave because I go berserk well you left
me anyhow and then the days got worse
and worse and now you see I've gone
completely out of my mind and they're
coming to take me away they're coming to
take me away
to the funny farm where Life is
Beautiful all the time I'll be happy to
see those nice young men in their clean
white coats they're coming to take me
away
good job
[Applause]
I might leave these on this is kind of
cool
it's very Tom Cruise yeah I feel like uh
that thing you do remember the drummer
in that thing yeah he wore glasses all
the time I'm Spartacus
um we asked folks to uh send in pictures
of stuff when they traveled with towns
that have [__] up names and we didn't
come up with a name for this bit so we
call it your Town's got a [__] up name
[Music]
this came from Jerry Bradley he was in
Norway this isn't exactly a town name
but these signs are everywhere
throughout Norway here's what you see
when you go to Norway
oh
fart stumper
Fox Tampa means another name for ass I
mean speed bump it does it really yes
fox dumpa in Norway is a speed bump a
speeding ticket in Norway is a fart spot
a traffic camera is a farts camera and a
speed trap is a fart control
and if you stick booze up your ass it's
farts drinking farts chugging
folks also send in emails about stuff
that's meant for kids kids are supposed
to enjoy these things uh we have found
out when we look at them that they're
inappropriate toys
[Music]
Aaron Michael Thomas of North Carolina
writes my daughter came up with a book
recently from the library and I couldn't
wait it to get the [__] out of my house
the title on the cover is well we'll
show you the cover here right now it's
called Matilda who told such Dreadful
lies
but then the cover as you can see the
title goes dot dot dot it's not the
complete cover they didn't put they
didn't put the title on it the complete
title is
who told says Dreadful lies and who was
burned to death
[__] that's like an American Girl Story
right there
I couldn't wait to get the children's
necromicon out of my own rights that's
not good for children I guess it's a
cautionary Tale But we want to buy that
book instantly if you lie you'll be
burned to death that's how we raised our
daughter well look at her now it's all
worked out no Barbies and [__]
burning at the stage you will burn if
you lie Damien from Liverpool uh in the
UK wrote in I saw this as opposed to
Liverpool in California there's a
Liverpool New York is it really yeah you
ever been there no
I saw this lunch box in the home and
bargain store in Liverpool and I thought
you might like to use it for
inappropriate toys Peppa Pig is a big
character there in the UK yes
um he's not quite sure what she's trying
to tell people on this lunch box you
tell me take a look
eat me yeah weird for a pig right it's
like I will well I won't I'm vegan but
somebody will either she's being Saucy
or she's inviting herself to be a ham
sandwich for someone but either way for
children it seems inappropriate I mean
the only thing more appropriate to
picture her and the other Pig and it
says bacon bacon laughs
Apple likes to make bacon
nice uh in Canada geekpool sends this in
I hope you can find this for me while
you're a Comic-Con he writes he's
looking for a particular action figure
of the Punisher this Punisher action
figures what he's looking for it's not
just an action figure it also turns into
a gun apparently oh it's a Transformer
yeah it transforms into a gun the second
picture there you go oh [__]
truly being punished and if you uh open
it all the way out it looks like
punisher's a bottom that's all I can
tell you which is surprising I didn't
see that happening at all
foreign
[Music]
ER when he's like that oh yeah
we also like to say goodbye to folks who
left us recently who left behind bodies
of work that we will love for many years
to come and dead bodies yes true we call
those our Tinseltown stiffs and now
another edition of
[Music]
they will be missed actress singer model
Jane Birkin has passed away at the age
of 76. she was a British singer actor
and style icon in the 1960s worked in
such films as the classic blow up she
was in death on the Nile Evil Under the
Sun but best known as a model and a
fashion trend Center Setter she was the
inspiration to erme to make the famous
Birkin handbag if you're familiar with
our Birkin handbag oh this is I think it
was on Sex in the City it's very yeah
it's a very expensive famous handbag
based on her here's what she looked like
in her Heyday back in the 1960s so um
she passed away at the age of 76. so old
nah it's not old do you have a picture
of the handbag I don't no fair enough
I
I don't think a picture of a handbag
would really go over it defined her
[__] life I know but she's dead she
won't know
it's fine she's dead she will be missed
and this one hurt uh Tony Bennett the
legendary Tony Bennett died again
I thought he had passed away already he
just died three days ago I thought he
had passed away see booze makes you
cruel yes so mad again how many times
that [__] guy gonna die
so tired of him and his death I didn't
know that he was still alive I thought
he passed away no 96 passed away at the
age of 96. [__] huge man what a great
[__] long life that was and what a
legendary career absolutely one of the
few singers where Sinatra said that guy
knows how to sing a song is that right
you can't ask for better than that he
was diagnosed with Alzheimer's disease
for a while back in 2016 and maybe
that's what I'm thinking of even with
his diagnosis they say he was playing
piano singing and recording right up
until his death just not publicly
70 albums over seven decades Jesus 19
Grammy Awards most recently he recorded
and toured with Lady Gaga back in the
early 2020s and just one of the greats
96 years old a great run a great career
can't ask for much more than that here's
the late Tony Bennett
I miss the Saturday dance
[Music]
I heard they crowded the floor
it's awfully different Without You
[Music]
Don't Get Around Much Anymore
my father was a give it up for the late
grade Tony Bennett thank you thank you
very much everybody else I love you I
love you like this always doing this
always doing this you're marvelous thank
you ladies and gentlemen I Left My Heart
in San Fran thank you you're marvelous
thank you so much pretty good my old man
was a country and western uh fan but
that was the one guy he [__] with
wasn't country Tony we love Tony Bennett
classic yeah he liked he liked this he
liked that he sang like that I remember
having that conversation with my father
I was like what do you like about him he
goes he sings like this
I was like Anne he's gone I just like
that style it's loose loose man I
remember asking him later in life like
when I grew up and whatnot I could joke
around with my father more I was like
Dad Tony Bennett shows up and he wants
to [__] mom what do you do oh Jesus
and my dad literally at an age [__] I
think he was 62 when I had this
conversation goes I watch
thank you you're marvelous thank you so
much I'm gonna [__] Grace now and you're
also wonderful thank you for watching
everybody
I stuck my car
inside your wife now thank you you're
marvelous thanks for watching
we like to pay tribute
to bad acting on this show and no not
just by showing me in yoga hosers no bye
celebrating acting that is so bad it
goes all the way around it becomes
Exquisite acting
[Music]
that is the question welcome to the
world of Exquisite acting with Ralph
Garman and Kevin Smith all right uh this
comes from Malcolm Boyd thank you
Malcolm for sending this in Blind Fury
is the film and what you if you've
subscribe Rutger Howard yeah it was like
the original Daredevil that's right when
it came out I was like holy [__] this is
like Daredevil except it's not Marvel
he's a blind Vietnam vet who has extra
Century sensory perception and Century
perception he's got a hundred different
perceptions
um and so he's got a heightened hearing
and heightened senses and he uh fights
crime so it is kind of like Derek I
remember that I remember being like holy
[__] and this particular film we're not
singling out Rutger Howell those
performance in this is wonderfully awful
no in this particular scene wait for the
person who has one line
[Applause]
26 black
hard luck fella
abastg babies it's me Kevin Smith Jason
you have you ever wanted to get lost on
the high seas with Jay and Silent Bob
well now you're gonna have your chance
go to Jay and Silent Bob
cruisesque.com right now and sign up for
Jay and Silent Bob's Cruise Askew we're
gonna hit the high seas where we going
Gilligan we're gonna be going to Miami
to Nassau Bahamas and into Norwegian
Pearl doesn't that sound great it's
gonna be me and him it's gonna be all of
our friends we'll be doing live podcasts
there's going to be a movies on board
there's going to be a viewer skew Museum
great times to be had by all ladies and
gentlemen tickets available right now go
buy a man and if you sign up before June
23rd it's only 100 down per cabin what
are you waiting for man get lost at sea
with Jay and Silent bone let's do it we
call this [__] that should not be
[Music]
here's some [__] that should not be
this comes from Nathan Moore he writes
in if you
help
right
I know I feel
he writes in this scene from The Abyss
where there's a giant tsunami who's
coming it's coming in to wipe everyone
off the planet and everyone on the beach
is running and then suddenly thanks to
Ed Harris who uh I don't know he blows
an alien or something and makes
everything stop and he makes the tsunami
stop mid tsunami yes and everybody is
Spellbound by the fact that tsunami is
not moving forward if you watch this
scene especially pay attention to the
lower left hand corner of this scene
you'll see some [__] that should not be
[Music]
thank you
oh [__]
[Laughter]
it's a random position do you think Jim
Cameron was responsible for that someone
would have spotted that
he's like pantsed while the world's
coming to an end we're gonna die but
it's never too late to pants one of your
friends it's too serious we need a
pantsing in this moment I'd like to see
somebody's bare ass before the the whole
thing comes they're trying to get their
R rating that's how they earned it God
that's a great [__] flick aside from
the pantsing
which now it actually makes it a little
better even better yes we'd like to take
a look at all the entertainment news
each time we do the show we call those
the HBO headlines
[Music]
indeed Jamie Foxx back at work amen give
it up for Jamie Foxx first time since
his hospitalization there's so many
reports but like he's hovering near
death it's all over yeah he's got the
covet virus and it made him grow a
second head I didn't hear that but wow
yeah that was him
um no one still knows what was wrong but
we know he's back to work he was
shooting a commercial for bet MGM which
is uh the betting service that he's been
connected with for some time he was in
Las Vegas shooting it with a Formula One
race car and by all accounts he's
healthy and happy and and back to work
so whatever it was that way laid him
apparently he's okay he's a wonderful
actor man good for you give it up for
James still alive
[Applause]
we finally have a resolution to tree
gate as we're calling it in Southern
California I don't know if you're
familiar with this story or not Kevin
but along the outside of the gates of
Universal Studios where the wga and
sag-aftra were walking the picket line I
have struck there I went and struck with
Mark Bernard and we as writers we uh
struck at Universal did you see the big
ficus trees along the way there that
gave you shade while you were marching
well those trees were trimmed down to
the trunk recently and a lot of people
on the picket line said the NBC
Universal was doing that just to make
things more uncomfortable for the
strikers because it's been a heat wave
in Los Angeles
particularly in the valley it's really
bad and Universal said no we just that's
how we just we just trimmed the trees
sometimes that way that's all and so the
city stepped in and they said well first
of all that's not Universal's trees to
do it's City trees we only trim those
once every five years so it certainly
wasn't us so someone trend them without
our permission and without a permit to
trim it so someone's going to be held
responsible for this so it was an
Insidious plot it was indeed an
Insidious plot and finally justice has
been served NBC Universal has been
slammed with a fine of 250 dollars for
what they've taught so at least justice
has been served they're going to lose
all that Oppenheimer money that's right
there's no way they're going to bounce
back from a fine of that size 250 bucks
I mean I don't care how many tickets you
sell to the Universal Studios tour
you're just making that money back
they're making that on soda in the first
five minutes
can you believe that so little man I
thought maybe 250 000. I was hoping
we'll never do that again but for 250
bucks they're like let's do that [__]
again how much if we shoot the picketers
like like a hundred bucks a person we
can afford that easily
Lindsay Lohan's in the news
she's a mother she welcomed her first
baby into the world this week I can tell
you're all thrilled congratulations
she had a baby boy Louie Louie shamas is
his name Louie in Arabic means Shield or
protector so apparently she uses her
baby as a human shield I'm guessing
she's looking for now best of luck to to
mother and son and I hope that maybe
this is a new beginning for her she's
had a rough go of it yeah in her own
childhood I hope Louie has a better go
of it she's making a new Freaky Friday
movie I've heard they're going to come
back with Jamie Lee Curtis and she plays
a mom who has a kids yeah she can
[__] draw from reality maybe all
three of them can [__] change their
personalities it'd be like [__] nuts
do you think that's what [__] happens
I hope so I hope Jamie Lee Curtis
becomes a muelling spitting up baby
child
that'd be hilarious and then she wins
another Oscar that's right
congratulations to Taylor Swift she has
become the first woman to have four
albums on the Billboard's top 10 at the
same time how is that possible well she
recorded re-recorded all of her biggest
albums and re-released them so all of
her fans went out and bought them again
which is [__] genius yes you should
refilm all of your movies and re-release
those that's true oh my God I can make
clerks even cheaper this time that's
right
uh four four albums the top ten of the
Billboard top 100 charts so
congratulations to her the only other
Living Art is to do so was herp Albert
oh [__] Herb Albert 1966 had three four
albums on the top ten at the same time
including whipped cream and other
Delights do you remember that album
here's the cover of that album my
parents had that I used to jerk off to
that album all the time looks like you
did jerk off
that's my own personal copy I brought
that in
the only person to do that is not a
living artist Prince after his death in
2016 had five albums in the top ten that
makes sense very best of Prince Purple
Rain the hits and b-sides ultimate in
1999. so Taylor Swift finally making
some money I'm happy to see her it looks
great at least I think she's gonna make
like a billion dollars in her tour this
year seriously yeah we should strike
against her for whatever reason whatever
reason she seems to have all the money
she should share it with somebody
have you uh did you ever watched The
Bachelor on ABC never once not once ever
I used to watch
for a while early on and it's it's like
any reality show if you invest the time
you get a caught up in it it's good uh
this brand new series is arriving I
don't know exactly when it's going to
drop but they just announced the golden
Bachelor ever heard about this no the
golden Bachelor is uh old age Bachelor
yes take my money right
Ted lasso wants the old age Bachelor I
don't know whether he has to watch it or
he just wants an old age Bachelor I'm
not sure
this is an older man who is going to be
having to choose from 25 older women
just at the same premise as the bachelor
only all the ages are Advanced instead
of stupid 25 year old women vying for an
idiot 30 year old man it's going to be
stupid 65 year old women
buying for a 71 year old Bachelor so
they just released the photo and
identity of the golden Bachelor this
week Jerry Turner 71 years old here he
is oh [__] that's what I'm saying that's
what 71. he's 71. [__] this guy I know
really he doesn't need a TV show to get
laid they literally could have just done
the bachelor with him they didn't have
to do the golden pass 71 and oh we oh
poor 71 year old Jerry let's try to find
him a date yet this [__] that guy yes I
would so Ritter used to be up there Josh
you in a hurry tonight you got some
place to go all right
that guy
that is an attractive [__] man he's
got like a mini crow's feet and that's
[__] it I wish I looked like that at
31 years old let alone 71 years old I
hope they line up white-haired women for
him man he's just like I'm used to
dating much younger all the eligible
women are we 65 years of age or older
and I'm sure they'll be unnaturally
attractive as well right he also was
married for 43 years to his high school
sweetheart who suddenly fell ill and
died Jesus Christ can you make this guy
any more attractive to women
I'm gonna do a staple in the AmEx card
to his forehead
I'm sure his [__] wife on her
deathbed was just like you should marry
someone else on television
find love on a reality show
good for him on so many levels and [__]
[__] if I I wish I looked like that at
52 that's what I'm saying good looking
man if they're gonna do old Bachelor do
some old broken down busted ass
[__] who can't get [__] laid
exactly and like dangle some cash in
front of these Broad and say
dish come on have a heart [__] this guy
that would be the show I would watch
I'm gonna call it come on [__] this guy
oh I think it's a better time
[__] this guy coming to ABC this fall
c-u-m-m-i-n-g
oh look who's in the news Justin [__]
Bieber's in the news Justin Bieber
[Music]
that's right
bad news for Justin Bieber which just
makes my [__] day by the way
back in 2020 in January Justin Bieber
entered the nft market and bought
himself the board ape be familiar with
the board that was very popular yes it
was so popular he paid 1.3 million
dollars for the board ape when was it uh
January of 2022 is when we were talking
about a year and change ago yeah here's
Justin and the ape you be the judge
which one is which
uh that was 1.2 million 1.3 million
dollars in January of 2022 that's the
board AP purchased it's a rare rare
piece very rare very rare it turns out
not so rare actually it sported a rarity
rank of
9810 I'm not familiar with the board ape
nft Market but apparently not that
particularly rare but the price has
dropped let me think just a little bit
let me see as of last week it was worth
fifty nine thousand dollars
you can buy that now for 59 000 and he
paid 1.5 1.3 million dollars so that 59
000 has been close to the point three of
that [__] equation you're absolutely
right like imagine if he paid 0.3 and
he's like [__] it's only worth fifty
thousand but he paid a million dollars
over that yes he needs to hook up with
[__] Taylor Swift right away yes he
does he get along he has all the [__]
money go on the [__] Bachelor
they're doing that on ABC sometime
should we do a little geek news since
we're downstairs
[Music]
we haven't talked since the uh casting
announcement for Superman Legacy yeah
what do you think
um I've I've the lowest Lane casting I
like Rachel Brosnahan of course The
Marvelous Mrs maisel I interviewed her
at uh Sundance for IMDb years back and I
thought she was really cool she got
spunk yeah much like Lois Lane she's got
spunk yeah uh how about this David Corn
sweat
Superman super Superman yeah um I'm
unfamiliar but he looked pretty sure not
as pretty as the [__] golden Bachelor
but yeah right
uh other casting we've been uh informed
about Isabella Merced as as Hawk Girl Mr
terrific as Edie gathegi and Guy Gardner
of course greenlander is Nathan Fillion
but the one that really has me super
excited is Anthony Kerrigan if any of
you guys watched Barry yeah he's been
cast as metamorpho the Elephant Man
let's go Jesus Christ could it be more
right that's cool casting right there
that is awesome and this will be the
first time we've ever seen metamorpho in
film I always loved that character as a
kid too those aren't familiar he's he's
all made of elements and he can change
those elements to become pretty much
anything he wants badass character yeah
so that's cool man yeah so far so good I
mean like once the strike's over maybe
they can go back to work and make that
movie maybe maybe we can all just
imagine what the movie was
uh Netflix has announced Masters of the
Universe the live-action version not
gonna happen at that streamer holy [__]
and I got blamed for it I saw that
online there's a bunch of people on
Twitter thanks Kevin Smith like in the
thanks Obama [__] voice and [__] I
was like our cartoon we have a sequel to
our cartoon Revolution it's an animation
on this side live action over here that
you have nothing to do with each other
and the Variety article was just like
well the budget was 200 million and
Netflix is like we don't want to do that
and [__] because they just took a hit
recently because their numbers weren't
quite worthless enough but the calculus
online for a bunch of people were like
you [__] did it well done [__]
clerks boy and I'm like I have nothing
to do with it man like our cartoon is
still [__] happening we just had a
panel on Thursday and announced that
hordak is being voiced by uh the great
[__] Keith David oh my God
what a great choice amongst many things
the president on Rick and Morty that's
awesome
is uh is uh festo coming back that's
just all of them well you're in it
you're [__] we you what you played on
the you forget that you [__] did a
voice thing I was just I was just
looking for a little little stroke
that's all um you we played a clip
um of the opening one of the opening
scenes the opening fight between uh
He-Man and scare glow
um and uh in subternia and you uh your
voice and your joke played [__] huge
that's good to know what yeah it was
[__] it was dope man I mean a little
more a little extra a little more
scratch yeah good it's good to know
speaking of superheroes Warner Brothers
uh in trouble with their Aquaman sequel
according to sources who know what
they're talking about another [__]
thing that people online are like Well
Done Kevin it's your fault too yeah
because of [__] Entourage remember
Entourage oh right they choke that
[__] like Kevin Smith was writing and
[__] yeah still to this day people come
up to me they're like I hear you're
right in Aquaman too and this is before
Aquaman one even happened and [__] I was
like they didn't even make an Aquaman
[__] one how could I be writing two
but yeah people it's funny that Aquaman
was the joke of that series and then it
became the most successful of all the DC
comic book made it over a billion
dollars at that movie so they're very
precious about this sequel as you can
imagine and so they've gone through
non-stop test screenings and they've
done three different sets of reshoots
and they're waiting to do another so
apparently they have to wait till the
strike is over to do yet another set of
reshoots and Jason Momoa like has he
didn't dissed the movie but he was like
I tried to give him ideas and they said
no they're not interested yeah
apparently there's a lot of trouble with
this they've gone through two different
Batmans in it as well apparently Michael
Keaton was in at one point and they
replaced him with Ben Affleck and then
Warner said well we don't want to
promise people Ben F like as Batman
because he's not going to be anymore so
it's another cutting them both now
they're cutting them all completely out
these are the movies I want to see I
want to see all that cut footage man
right yeah [__] so we'll have to wait
and see and speaking of Comic Con if you
guys saw this or not they're talking
about it a lot on the convention floor
but uh Comic-Con taking to the seas in
2025. have you heard about this no you
haven't heard about Comic-Con the cruise
I've heard about uh the Jay and Silent
Bob cruises Q which we'll both be on
what it's on screens all over the
[__] place
they stole the idea for you man
Comic-Con has announced they're going to
be going Comic-Con the cruise a full
ship Charter that goes from Tampa
Florida to the Mexican island of Cozumel
and it's happening in February of 2025
for the first time so if you'd like to
experience Comic-Con on the sea then uh
you can do Comic-Con the cruise which is
great because the celebrities can't get
away from you yes they'd have to jump
overboard and they're much too vain to
do that they're all H will be much
smaller on that boat I can imagine it
will but depending on who they get how
cool would it be if you can hang out
with you know Patrick Stewart by the
pool
put some sunscreen on me or something be
great
um what is so will they have like a
sales floor they're gonna have a sales
floor they're going to have uh
um events they're going to have panels
they're going to have q and A's and
signings and autograph sessions and
photo sessions so it's not a bad idea
where did you say leaves from uh Tampa
Florida why wouldn't it leave from San
Diego
right
well San Diego's not close to Mexico
Kevin that's ridiculous
what are you insane I know what was I
thinking I don't know why would they
leave from Tampa
I mean let me double check myself here
oh too far too far
um Tampa to the Mexico out of Cozumel
yeah aboard the Royal Caribbean Center
and Aid of the seed of the seed Seas
it's not the sea just the serenade of
the seed is something we do backstage
after the show
um four was it five days uh September
5th February 5th through the 9th
four days yeah cut them off
cut you off
in a car when he drives home
and lastly thank you to Matthew King for
sending this to us this is uh this is AI
used right this is AI use they asked um
AI to come up with if you're casting the
DC movies in the Golden Age of Hollywood
what these characters would look like
have you seen the results it's kind of
ridiculous let's burn through them real
quick can we start with the first one
Superman Rock Hudson is Superman oh [__]
it's pretty cool they should have put
that in the Flash
next up
Humphrey Bogart is Batman it's kind of
dope yeah she I'm gonna stop crying
because my parents were killed
I'd watch that totally totally next up
Wonder Woman Catherine Hepburn as Wonder
Woman I come from an island of all women
we have bracelets that you can bounce
bullets off
I'd watch that uh next up
yeah Gregory Peck is Aquaman
I'm under water
next up
Gene Kelly is The Flash
oh that's adorable right yeah because he
can dance and stuff he's fast next up
James Cagney is the joke and [__] what a
good idea what would that be and why why
is it yeah you dirty bat
oh top of the world Harley
yeah see
next up
Betty Davis is Harley Quinn oh my God be
pretty cool this is a cool concept
that's what I'm talking about recasting
from the Golden Age of Hollywood what's
up next
Rita Hayworth is poison ivy really nice
sexiest actress of the 40s playing the
sexiest
villain of Batman what's up next Josh
Catwoman you got Audrey Hepburn of
course the classic Audrey Hepburn
[__] choice this is badass they
should do this as a comic at least right
and then my favorite my personal
favorite Chuck Heston is Green Lantern
oh [__] what would that sound like
and Brightest Day
ah
a
Darkest Night
no evil shall Escape my sight let those
who
worship people worship evils might
be wherever beware of my power amen
Green Lanterns
ah
right
that's great would that be
Dr zayas
that's a good [__] idea that somebody
came up with man that's what I'm saying
it's AI as our friend not as our enemy
truly but that starts like that and then
it [__] takes over that's right yes
all right before we say good night boys
and girls thank you so much for being
here we appreciate it
it's been an amazing audience kids we've
got one last bit of business of course
we have to talk about the enormous penis
of Liam Neeson that's one of our
favorite things to talk about
[Music]
Liam Neeson famously one of the biggest
penises in Hollywood and each week you
guys send in facts about his penis you
can send us facts about his penis or
anything you want to at HBO podcast
aol.com don't mock we still use it the
oldest [__] email address on the
planet but no one else is using it's
great we're all alone over there at AOL
no one bothers us it's lovely it's true
nobody uses HBO either I'm surprised you
haven't changed it to Max at AOL.com Max
podcast
um before we get to jump in let's just
all take a moment and appreciate this is
the last bit that we'll ever do at
Hollywood Babylon at Comic-Con 2023 man
wow that's how we end it
let's Savor this when you're a drinker
you get emotional about this it's true
yeah like an unnecessary [__] love
you man yes no this is the left no [__]
no [__] no [__] this is the last [__]
bit we're gonna [__] ever gonna do it
at a Comic-Con 2023 man let's just
[__] let's just [__] let that
[__] soak in I love you man I [__]
love you I wish you were that kind of
drug that'd be amazing
uh before we dive into that too kids uh
how many people are taking pictures of
me and Ralph after this put your hands
together
this guy's gonna cut me off
uh how many Picture People want to join
that [__] picture line with me around
put your hands together
you can jump over to the booth and you
can add photos and come up and take
pictures of this after the thing's all
done and [__] like that we're gonna have
as soon as we go upstairs we're doing
this Posey thing wearing pants this time
we will wear pants no butt chugging
allowed all right fair enough
[Laughter]
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
[Applause]
Marvel announced today at Comic-Con it
will play Galactus in the new Fantastic
Four move oh my God breaking news
that'll bring everybody back to Marvel
for sure yes it will Liam needs his [__]
is so big
Liam's neighbors asked him not to
sunbathe on the roof any longer their
plants are dying I think we have a
picture of that of him
yeah
backyard there's not doing like the
opening of Star Wars and [__]
Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
sadly Liam was also fired from his job
as an air traffic controller I think we
have a picture of that as well
I could do this all day
Liam needs his [__] is so big
and one once ate an entire birthday cake
all by itself before its friends could
tell it there was a stripper inside
sad
always sad when strippers do yeah yeah
and lastly Liam Neeson's [__] is so big
[Applause]
his explosions are more powerful than
oppenheimers no [__] ladies and
gentlemen of Comic-Con 2023 if you had a
good time this evening
thank you so much for hanging with us we
truly appreciate it we couldn't have a
show without you but there is no shower
with Man without the man sitting to my
left give it up for the amazing the
legendary Ralph [__] Garmin
let's hear it from my bestest Babel
brother and Buddy Mr Kevin Smith
and a big shout out for Dr Josh Rouse
and that is Hollywood Babylon for this
week I'm Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman
top of the [__] off good night San Diego
[Applause]
give it up for Ralph Garmin and Kevin
Smith
foreign
greetings everybody and welcome to the
AKA ask Kevin every Saga has a 10-year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and Silent
Bob get old off Kevin Smith
[Music]